Cool scars were like a huge part of childhood,
like one scar on that one dudes forehead,
or that scar on that mean lion.. what’s
his name?
But like, what are scars?
Why do we get them?
Hey guys, julia here for DNews
Last week we got a great question from Richard
Colinge asking How do scars form?
And why do they have a different texture and
look?
Well Richard you’ve got some great questions
and we’ve got some answers!
So in your skin and other tissues, your cells
are all connected by what’s called an extracellular
matrix.
This ECM as it’s called helps cells exchange
nutrients and share information.
It’s mostly made up of collagen, a strong
fibrous kind of material, secreted by cells
called fibroblasts.
Usually the ECM is in a random basket weave
type formation.
Scars form when there’s a wound.
When your body is wounded, white blood cells
surround the area to stave off any infection.
Your body tries to hold together the edges
of the wound by producing collagen from the
fibroblasts.
And white blood cells also help with the production
of collagen.
This collagen quickly forms to support the
wounded area.
Unfortunately, fibroblasts often produce too
much collagen after a wound.
And it isn’t in the same basketweave pattern,
it’s more in straight lines facing one direction.
With an excess of collagen in a weird pattern,
the tissue isn’t able to do the normal things
it’s supposed to.
Like sweat or grow hair.
And yes, skin cells do replace themselves
periodically, but while individual cells are
replaced, the underlying collagen is not.
So that’s why scars persist.
While scars can be helpful and supportive
in wound healing, they can also be damaging.
Collagen isn’t very flexible, so sometimes
a buildup of scar tissue leads to serious
health problems.
All tissues scar as they repair themselves,
not just your skin.
This includes internal tissues like ligaments
and organs.
If scar tissue in your organs forms, it’s
called fibrosis, even if it’s not caused
by a wound but by an autoimmune disorder or
illness.
Such a build up can cause chronic health problems
like cystic fibrosis causes damage to the
lungs and sometimes other organs like kidneys
and liver.
So besides being slightly unsightly, scars
can mess things up.
So scientists are working on ways to stop
scar production.
One study published in the journal Nature
Cell Biology found a way to turn down fibroblasts
activity.
The researchers discovered that after a while,
fibroblasts enter a state of senescence, meaning
they don’t reproduce.
The senescent cells stopped making collagen
and even contributed to breaking it down.
The researchers also discovered a specific
protein called CCN1 that actually induced
the senescent state in fibroblasts.
So they created a topical cream that contained
that protein, and lo and behold actually stopped
scars from forming… in mice.
So more research is needed on that front.
Anyway I hope that answers your questions,
Richard!
Switching gears for a second, GUYS GUYS GUYS.
We’re having a space hang out!
As NASA is about to fly-by Pluto, we're doing
a live Google Hangout with our awesome space
producer Ian O'Neill and a special guest INSIDE
MISSION CONTROL!
WHAT CRAZY RIGHT?!
I’m so stoked.
It’s all happening July 14 at 1pm Pacific
4pm Eastern.
SO be there or be square!
RSVP on the event page for a reminder!
Theres a link down in the description too!
Alrighty, so do you any of you guys have a
cool scar?
One that looks like a perfect map of the london
underground perhaps?
Tell us about it down below!